[Music]
after witnessing the violent rage shown
by babies
whenever deprived of an item they
considered their own Jean Piaget a
founding father of child psychology
observed something profound about human
nature our sense of ownership emerges
incredibly early
why are we so clingy there's a
well-established phenomenon in
psychology known as the endowment effect
where we value items much more highly
just as soon as we own them in one
famous demonstration students were given
a choice between a coffee mug or a Swiss
chocolate bar as a reward for helping
out with research half chose the mug and
half chose the chocolate that is they
seemed to value the two rewards
similarly other students were given a
mug first and then a surprise chance to
swap it for a chocolate bar but only 11%
wanted to yet another group started out
with chocolate and most preferred to
keep it rather than swap in other words
the students nearly always put greater
value on whichever reward they started
out with part of this has to do with how
quickly we form connections between our
sense of self and the things we consider
ours that can even be seen at the neural
level in one experiment neuro scientists
scanned participants brains while they
allocated various objects either to a
basket labelled mine or another labeled
Alex's when participants subsequently
looked at their new things
their brains showed more activity in a
region that usually flickers in to life
whenever we think about ourselves
another reason we're so fond of our
possessions is that from a young age we
believe they have a unique essence
psychologists showed us this by using an
illusion to convince 3 to 6 year olds
they built a copying machine a device
that could create perfect replicas of
any item when offered a choice between
their favorite toy or an apparently
act copy the majority of the children
favored the original in fact they were
often horrified at the prospect of
taking home a copy this magical thinking
about objects isn't something we grow
out of rather it persists into adulthood
while becoming ever more elaborate for
example consider the huge value placed
on items that have been owned by
celebrities it's as if the buyers
believed the objects they'd purchased
were somehow imbued with the essence of
their former celebrity owners for
similar reasons many of us are reluctant
to part with family heirlooms which help
us feel connected to lost loved ones
these beliefs can even alter our
perception of the physical world and
change our athletic abilities
participants in a recent study
we're told they were using a golf putter
once owned by the champion Ben Curtis
during the experiment they perceived the
hole as being about a centimeter larger
than control participants using a
standard putter and they sank slightly
more putts
although feelings of ownership emerge
early in life culture also plays a part
for example it was recently discovered
that hodza people of northern Tanzania
who are isolated from modern culture
don't exhibit the endowment effect
that's possibly because they live in an
egalitarian society where almost
everything is shared at the other
extreme sometimes our attachment to our
things can go too far part of the cause
of hoarding disorder is an exaggerated
sense of responsibility and
protectiveness toward one's belongings
that's why people with this condition
find it so difficult to throw anything
away what remains to be seen today is
how the nature of our relationship with
our possessions will change with the
rise of digital technologies many have
forecast the demise of physical books
and music but for now at least this
seems premature perhaps there will
always be something uniquely satisfying
about holding an object in our hand
and calling it our own
[Music]
you